the interest wasn't oversight the
interest was a political hit job on the
FBI in the service of the President the
goal here is to undermine the FBI
discredit the FBI discredit the Muller
investigation do the president's bidding
Adam Schiff the ranking member of the
House Intelligence Committee still on a
tear about the GOP memo that alleges the
FBI and DOJ abused the FISA process to
surveil former Trump campaign adviser
caught a page Democrats want their own
version out to the public and there
could be a vote on that soon meanwhile
the president called Schiff one of the
biggest liars and leakers in Washington
who must be stopped
today the congressman is firing back mr.
president I see you've had a busy
morning of executive time the primary
author of the memo Devin Nunez piling on
his Democratic colleague if you look
what they've done over the course of the
last couple weeks since we put together
our memo so that we could make sure the
American public discovered the FISA
abuses that occurred they've continued
to leak out bits and pieces of
information to create narratives that
quite frankly have have one thing in
common they're always false mr. Schiff a
knows that he's spreading a false
narrative there but that's not new for
him he spread false narrative the entire
time
okay so the president Dana calling him a
liar and a leaker who must be stopped
today I wanna I know so over the weekend
I tried to like take a step back and I
figured let's just I'm gonna let all of
this settle and then read a couple more
things when I start on Monday just to
see where people are and I feel like
it's the same we're at same place that
we were on Friday except for that the
Democrats have sort of advanced their
agenda by one responding to the
president the way that they had after he
well whether it's punching or counter
punch II and I have lost count I do
think that this question of whether the
underlying documents are going to be
revealed is still an open question on
Friday night Devon Nunez was on Bret
Baier show for an exclusive interview
and Bret asked him if he had read the
underlying documents and he said no but
that trey Gowdy had the congressman from
South Carolina's overseen the
the Oversight Committee and I'm
wondering about if the intelligence
committee folks are not all read in on
exactly what's happening underneath
should these documents actually be
released in all of us because I don't
know what the context is and I don't
know if it's a really good idea to start
disseminating to the public information
that is supposed to be for
investigations I think it's kind of
dangerous the other thing is I just feel
like a lot of the timeline doesn't make
sense to me especially that the memo
talks about Carter page and the spice'
warrant in October of 2016 when he left
the campaign a month before in September
and then according to the timeline the
counterintelligence investigation
started three months before that so I'm
not even sure what Carter page could
have even told anybody on somewhat of
any sort of wiretap that would have been
relevant to the Trump campaign if he'd
left so I think there's a lot of open
questions okay so I'm a great Dana
thinks perhaps it might be you know an
imprudent escalation to then try to now
release the Democratic side and go back
and forth okay with the recent I think
the Democrats should be allowed I just
wonder about things these underlying
under me it's kind of the underlying
documents and perhaps obviously could
have some national security implications
I just I've always first to state the
obvious we're seeing this is another
example of team sport politics Minds me
of that I think we did this segment on
the 5:00 what was the color of the dress
and some people saw the color of the
dress as gold so one side will we see
this one way one side would see the
other having said that Andrew McCarthy I
think really nailed it down in National
Review he responded to Gerald not
nailers letter and he says it's not it's
not about steel being reputable in his
dossier it's not about him being you
know he's an upstanding guy it's not
about that it's about his sources
remember he didn't write the dossier he
simply delivered it so the FBI and the
DOJ should have been more put more
emphasis on that because somebody to
anybody a capable person could put
together report on you with unvetted
sources are you happy that the
government used a capable person then
that's okay with you that they use
anonymous sources saying crappy stuff
about you so that's important but the
thing that kind of gets me is the Dems
you keep hearing this like releasing
this a memo as a constitutional crisis
well
how can that be a constitutional crisis
and trying to unseat
a president this general election not be
a constitutional crisis I think that I
think trying to steal an election from
the American public
yes is a constitutional crisis releasing
an obviously a memo that has some kind
of political opinion in it let's be
honest it's done by a Republican there's
gonna be again there's two sides so that
is far from a crisis but somehow
generating and ginning up this scandal
to steal an election that's a crisis I
agree or it could be a quite a second
wait a second a scandal the scandal was
that the Russians interfere in our
election there's no rush it's interfere
in everything no we know we should
minimize it no no this is about
collusion I'm waiting for the okay but
I'm just saying if you have a clear-cut
case on collusion and you try to impeach
Trump and something happens you got a
big problem on your hands it's 67
million people who are gonna wage war
let me tell you I mean you can portray
this as some kind of coup but that cool
would have been if in fact we have a
candidate running as an agent of a farm
three but you have nothing there compute
what ifs are beautiful they are
what about Russians interfering in this
interference briefing favoring Donald
Trump and you can't blame the president
for that he didn't call up with a brush
interfere with the election did you
choose me right the Trump Tower with a
ruggedized aim for looking for dirt on
Hillary clearly the does the information
come from
Russians oh please let me just say let's
to go back to Dana's point about this is
we wanna make sure he's still alive
totally makes no sense Devin newness is
attempt to say that the timeline fits
and this is the basis because guess what
they are ready we're looking at Carter
page from 2030 and why would they look
at him he was actually cooperating with
the FBI
cuz the rulers tried to recruit him Greg
yes and he cooperated on my game
cooperated let me get this you may not
be the brightest I am being under the
table too in order to aware you why
would I look into the table because
that's weird why not release the
Democrats you guys are always but
truthfully you do wait Donald Trump says
he's vindication straw man while Romney
Trump is a strong argument for releasing
the memo you're sure my goodness this is
getting crazy so to me gently do this
make less fans Jesse momma officials
used fake information and got the court
to justify spying on the Trump campaign
they lied to the court one you think it
was a live emission the the dossier was
the reason for the spying they did not a
dossier was kept from the judge they
didn't say that it was paid for by
Hillary wait a second I see now you're
saying that they did hacia it was paid
for by Hillary and it's real I the judge
why didn't they tell the judge that lon
they there as they knew they wouldn't
have gotten the spying done it isn't for
that you know how weak you are because
this we just won the shoe we must
separate the fans from the players weak
you are one it is not scandal on your
side why is everybody getting demoted
why's everybody retired early wait what
are you talking about rep H struck page
Lisa not all these people on that side
must be guilty of something because
they're actually now getting in trouble
the other thing is you're spying on
Carter page yeah for all these years
while collusion yes it even been charged
you was cooperating he hasn't even been
charged one over there for the
and now there's more memos coming so
that's why you guys are getting remotely
clear oh well none of it is but that
that anything that they that the
government would have been listening to
with Carter page when she's not even on
the campaign anymore would even relate
back to the Trump campaign or the Trump
family in any way cuz he wasn't involved
so maybe there was a problem in getting
the warrant and that needs to be looked
into but I also think that the Trump
family at this point I don't know why he
would be concerned about Carter page
being listened in on because he wouldn't
wouldn't have known anything oh and
speaking if you want to learn more about
Carter page then you should watch the
Ingraham angle tonight cuz he's gonna be
with Laura